botte en touche en plaçant le curseur
sur les partis politiques aussi c'est à
vous de prendre des décisions c'est à
vous de vous engager et lorsqu'on
pratiquer le dialogue il ne faut plus se
mettre en avant il faut réussir à mettre
les autres en avant c'est aussi un signe
qu'il est plus dans un axe de dialogue
que de pure rhétorique
à la lumière des premiers choix des
premières expressions des groupes
politiques de notre assemblée nationale
nous commencerons à bâtir cette méthode
est cette configuration nouvelle si vous
voulez nous sommes dans une
communication dite de l'incertitude et
des 70 certitude elle a un effet négatif
au sein de l'audience l'audience
commence à douter elle va remettre en
question la légitimité de celui ou celle
qui doit décider c'est ce qu'on appelle
une audience qui devient sceptiques le
24 avril vous m'avez renouveler votre
confiance en m'élisant président de la
république vous l'avez fait sur le
fondement d'un projet clair et en me
donnant une légitimité clair il parle de
la légitimité que les français ont
accordé au président donc à emmanuel
macron et cette légitimité doit venir
consolider cette image qui est peut être
ébranlés par les récents événements
deuxième élément aussi qui consolide
l'image donc ce qu'on appelle en
rhétorique les taux ce qui consolide
cette image c'est la bienveillance il
tend la main aux partis emmanuel macron
va féliciter les parlementaires élus les
12 et 19 juin dernier vous avez voté
pour vos députés élire notre assemblée
nationale
je veux ici félicité les parlementaires
ayant emporté vos suffrages j'ai aussi
une pensée pour les députés sortant
battu nous appelons ça en rhétorique la
captation de la bienveillance il ne se
place plus comme celui qui décide
uniquement mais comme celui qui félicite
celui qui veut le bien et ça c'est la
première partie du discours c'est
essentiel puisque l'incertitude
fragilise l'image il consolide son image
ensuite il pose un cadre transparent et
ça c'est essentiel aussi face à
l'incertitude il avoue qu'il y a des
fractures il dit et c'est un point
fondamental lorsque vous communiquer
avec des gens qui sont sceptiques de
votre capacité à agir a analysé je ne
peux d'abord ignoré la forte abstention
qui nous oblige tous à redonner
davantage de sens à nos actions
collectives de lisibilité au grand
rendez vous démocratique
voter est essentielle pour la vie de la
nation pour ces grands choix est très
clairement ce n'est plus ressentie par
tous
je ne peux pas davantage ignorer
les fractures les divisions profondes
qui traverse notre pays et se reflète
dans la composition de la nouvelle
assemblée elles expriment des
inquiétudes le sentiment d'avoir des
vies bloqué pas de perspective dans
nombre de nos quartiers populaires comme
dans nos villages
ces élections législatives ont fait de
la majorité présidentielle la première
force politique de l'assemblée nationale
toutefois et c'est un fait nouveau et
comme dans la plupart des démocraties
occidentales qu'il s'agisse de
l'allemagne de l'italie de beaucoup
d'autres aucune force politique ne peut
aujourd'hui faire les lois seul nous
devons collectivement apprendre à
gouverner et légiférer
différemment
cela ne doit pas vouloir dire
l'immobilisme
cela doit signifier des accords en
prenant le temps de les faire qu'est ce
qu'il fait il se projette il se projette
dans un futur si le statu quo est
conservé une fois qu'il a provoqué un
petit peu cette tension cette peur
le public at on des solutions je crois
qu'il est donc possible dans le moment
crucial que nous vivons de trouver une
majorité plus large et plus claire pour
agir il faudra clarifier dans les
prochains jours la part de
responsabilité et de coopération que les
différentes formations de l'assemblée
nationale sont prêtes à prendre pour
avancer utilement il revient maintenant
aux groupes politiques de dire en toute
transparence jusqu'où ils sont prêts à
aller et là encore c'est une main tendue
il se déresponsabilise aussi un petit
peu de la situation et il botte en
touche en plaçant le curseur sur les
partis politiques aussi c'est à vous de
prendre des décisions c'est à vous de
vous engager cette communication de
l'incertitude elle fait appel à des
notions qui ne sont pas que rhétorique
elle fait appel aussi à des notions qui
sont dialectique la dialectique c'est
l'art du dialogue et lorsqu'on pratiquer
le dialogue il ne faut plus se mettre en
avant il faut réussir à mettre les
autres en avant et c'est aussi ce qu'on
peut ressentir dans ce discours là
emmanuel macron parle des français
manuel marque on parle des forces
politiques de l'assemblée nationale
leur tend la main et cette posture
bienveillante envers les autres il les
félicite un du reste c'est aussi un
signe qu'il est plus dans un axe de
dialogue que de pure rhétorique non il
faut réparer ces fractures il faut il
faut il faut recoudre ce tissu qui c'est
qui s'est déchiré et la posture a
fondamentalement changé c'est toujours
intéressant de le rappeler parce que
c'est vraiment l'audience qui détermine
le discours et ce n'est pas l'émetteur
les maîtrise du message qui choisit les
tenants et les aboutissants du discours
à transmettre
[Musique]